[Musique]
bonsoir nos amis au soir bon les seuls
tu as une lettre je crois que c'est pour
vous pas trop montre mais oui monsieur
le marchand de sable elle met à dresser
je vais la lire en attendant prenez
votre temps moi je t'ai sans voir mes
deux petits avis europe pop hip hop hop
hop hop hop pour quelle drôle de l'être
qu'est ce qui est écrit que si c'est pas
écrit c'est tout cas bouyer bonsoir les
enfants
regardent ce qui vient d'arriver voyons
donc le
gourou du boulot
qu'est ce que ça veut dire monsieur
lourd chez mademoiselle pape rhône elle
est monsieur nicolas ont certainement
gamme les hommes sa route de doux à gogo
oui c'est curieux c'est écrit en ours
mais oui lisons la lettre la
coucou de douche ou chou chou putuo ou
lou didon roudaut new situent les un peu
en français on comprendra peut-être
quelque chose cette extraordinaire
incroyable c'est un cousin germain qui
habite au tyrol et qui m'invitent un
cousin germain
oui mon cousin
germain de ma mère il habite au tyrol
cher
c'est le tyran ou pas dit si un jour de
noir
sacré passe roubles ou new look
c'est un pays très beau plein de
montagne il faut que j'aille le voir
sacré à ce bijou blues
je crois qu'il faut dépêcher d'y aller
mais ne croyez ça vaut mieux de toute
façon comprend rien ton langage dos gros
globe le bijou à leur petit feu nos
loulous quoi je disais que je vous
rapporterait de beaux cadeaux la finance
miou miou miou bon ami revient vite il
n'oublie pas ceux promis loup à bientôt
fufu
à bientôt
ce pauvre nonce
tenue pape rhône elle fait beau rêve
nicolas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patron
patron ou du
pardon
j'aimerais aller au tyrol mon cousin
honte mieux but excellente idée nounours
je viens justement de recevoir une
gentille lettre de petits enfants
tyrolien qui me demande d'aller les voir
oublie on y va vous les emmurés et moi
je rendrai visite à moscou jean allons
en route gros new new bonne nuit des
enfants à bientôt à bientôt faite pour
vous
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]